27 - this was a year of really great
games
cuphead Verona getting over it absolvo
mario odyssey breath of the wild mario x
rabbits and shovel knight pub g duelist
for tonight went i've had so much fun
with all of these but it's a shame I
can't talk about them on the channel
because none of them are Dark Souls
related unless well when you think about
it cuphead is really just the brighter
happier Dark Souls of platform shooters
and I've heard absorber is nearly the
Dark Souls of fighting games and breath
of the wild really is a little like Dark
Souls if you know what as it turns out
everything is related to Dark Souls and
you know what that means it's time to
overuse and over saturate this Dark
Souls of the phrase so hard that no one
ever uses it again
so get ready everybody because this is
the Dark Souls of awards our first
category is the dark souls of souls like
games I make fun of the journalists who
overused their Dark Souls comparisons
this year not because I think it's a
huge travesty like some people but
admittedly it has created a trend that's
muddied the waters a bit when it comes
to games that actually deserve to be
called a Souls like game games like neo
the surge or even hollow Knight which
are undeniably inspired by souls to the
point where it's actually easier to
explain what these games do differently
than what they keep the same and some
people are angry at the word Souls like
because they think the word is redundant
and some are angry because they see
these games as uninspired
I don't think either of those things are
true and here we celebrate these games
not simply for their similarities to
souls but for the creative ways that
these developers have built upon a
design style that we love take the surge
for example I only played this recently
and I was pleasantly surprised at how
much tighter it felt than Lords of the
Fallen which is a game I didn't like
quite as much most importantly though
they actually built upon the souls
formula in a meaningful way this time
with the dismemberment mechanic so if
you focus your attacks on a unarmored
piece of an enemy's body then you'll
deal more damage but if you spy this
nice piece of gear or weaponry that your
opponent has you can focus your attacks
there and do less damage but eventually
hack it off and take it for your own
it's like every enemy has a boss tail in
a way and that is a mechanic that I
really really miss from the soul series
another fantastic nomination is neo
especially now that they've released the
complete edition on pc so pick it up
because i had a legitimate hunger for
the complex combat in this game the maps
are really well designed and the
japanese theme really lends itself well
to creative bosses and unique settings
and lastly this year there was also holo
night which I sincerely regret not
covering on the channel it has a ton of
challenging enemy types and it has this
gently oppressive sort of atmosphere
along with truly memorable characters
that you'll often hear humming the two
in the distance it's this example of a
game that screams consistency and
quality in the entirety of its design
the game just feels so complete so
thoughtfully designed and it definitely
deserves a place on this list though
admittedly it has less similarity to
souls than the other two and now the
moment you've all been waiting for
the game which can be rightfully called
the dark souls of souls like games the
hardest game on this list the most
brutally crushing the game that is
literally known for how tough it is
because that's really what Dark Souls is
all about right the winner is the crash
bandicoot remake for ps4 I kid but to
some people souls is defined by
literally only one thing its difficulty
because when you think about it it
doesn't matter if it has an ingenious
story it doesn't matter if it has deep
combat tight world design and unique
atmosphere because those things might as
well not exist at all if you can't get
past the tutorial the thing is souls
isn't defined by its difficulty but it
is undeniably made better because of it
and I see a lot of people struggling to
articulate why difficulty is good and
there's a lot of reasons but I think the
main one is that when good games are
difficult their mechanics are put to the
test and the player who succeeds at
defeating the game will have properly
experienced everything the game has to
offer every mechanic will be used to its
fullest and I think that is why proper
difficulty is important in a lot of
games this next category is for games
that inspire cries of despair followed
by retaliations of get good it's for
games that are difficult by design and
better for it
the dark souls of difficult video games
and no game this year ignited the debate
about
like a cup head cup head is an absolute
joy it's inspired by those
black-and-white cartoons of the 1930s
which is this really unique aesthetic
that I've never seen replicated in
gaming but as it turns out this
exaggerated animation style is perfect
for the sort of bullet-hell platformer
that Cup head is allowing bosses to
comically wind themselves up for a
memorable clearly foreshadowed attack
the soundtrack takes you back in time
and the overworld breaks up fights
perfectly and just witnessing a new boss
and ter wacky catalogue of attacks and
phases it's a reward unto itself even if
it gets you killed the game is oozing
bursting with character and I can almost
understand why some people were miffed
at not being capable of experiencing
every boss this challenging game has to
offer but not all games are made to be
completed by everyone in fact they've
kind of feel like some games weren't
meant to be completed at all I'm talking
of course about getting over it with
Bennett 40 I created this game for a
certain kind of person to hurt them at
least is honest I know that many of you
are that kind of person the kind of
person who completes something just to
say that they did the person who plays
for the internal reward not the external
reward because for a lot of us
difficulty isn't really a barrier it's
more of an experience the only way
you'll complete this game is if you
accept the fact that you've already lost
every bit of progress you just made only
then will you take the risks that you
need to in order to finish games are a
unique medium in that they have this
inherent ability to lock out the
unskilled player from an experience in
fact this is the reason why many early
video games were so crushingly difficult
it was impossible to fit a prolonged
experience on Wii
hardware so difficulty extended
replayability difficulty is baked into
gaming's DNA and while we've moved past
games needing to be artificially
difficult to extend playtime I think
good examples of difficulty should be a
topic of discussion and good discussion
about difficulty was not something I
sold this year in one corner we had a
couple of stubborn journalists who
begged for accessibility in exchange for
design integrity and in the other corner
we had the difficulty elitists who
overreact the main thought that games
could become more casual in anyway I
think cuphead deserves this award
because its difficulty drives you to
think critically about the best way to
tackle a boss or a level it has simple
modes that you can practice in or you
can play with a friend but at the end of
the day it's unapologetically difficult
and it is far better for it another
thing that's difficult is venting about
digital card games when you run a Dark
Souls Channel but today my moment has
finally arrived so this might come as a
bit of a surprise to you guys but over
the last couple of years I've really
enjoyed playing a bunch of card games in
my downtime I regrettably started with
hearthstone unboxing a golden legendary
in my first pack which sort of compelled
me to keep playing then I moved on to
duelist in 2016 which taught me just how
limited hearthstone was in scope and in
scale now in 2017 I've found my favorite
experience of all in Gwent the which a
card game which I can easily call the
dark souls of digital card games for
what that's worth but to understand just
how good quent is I kind of have to
drive home just how terrible hearthstone
is to its consumers as it's the most
popular card game and man I've been
waiting to say this for a long time so
I'm gonna
after about a year of quitting
hearthstone I can't help but laugh when
I tune into a stream and I see the exact
same cards causing the exact same
problems they were an exact year ago
their dev team has this terrible
hands-off approach to balancing their
game and they frequently deflect
responsibility by saying things like
well we don't want to confuse returning
players with different contexts or we
want players to find their own solutions
thing is there is very little room for
counter play in half stones RNG fiestas
and while I seriously doubt that they
will ever make this game skill intensive
digital card games benefit enormous ly
from the smallest balanced patches
perhaps more than any other genre
because good balanced patches can revive
whole sets of unused cards and disrupt
stale metas making the games sometimes
feel as fresh to play as when a new
expansion gets released while playing
this game I have never felt less
respected as a consumer this is a dev
team who didn't implement Dex slots for
years because they thought that they
would be too confusing to new players
this is the team that hasn't really
touched their ladder system since closed
beta even though their ladder system
incentivizes playing aggro decks that
win or lose games quickly this is the
team that prints RNG card after RNG card
building an experience with one goal to
get you addicted and don't get me wrong
like I think there are parts of hath
stones design that are brilliant and the
only games that I even bother
criticizing are the ones that I see a
ton of potential in but it is abundantly
clear that ha stones development team is
one of the most inactive teams in
Blizzard let alone the industry for how
successful the game
which I think really speaks to the
monopoly that hearthstone has on the
card game genre with more expansions
less single-player adventures and a 25%
increase in the base price of packs in
2017 it will cost you six hundred and
seventy US dollars to get 90 percent of
a hearthstone collection and you are
certainly not going to get a decent
collection with in-game gold that's for
sure they barely award you any for a
reason one thing I loved about duelist
was that they added four new cards every
month for free if you were ranked high
enough at the end of the month this gave
them the ability to print counters to
oppressive strategies in the meta and
they could solve balance problems
holistically without any nerves it kept
the game fresh it kept people coming
back and it incentivized the ranked
ladder duelist was fantastic while I
played it largely characterized by its
tiled game board movement and the
ability to replace one card every turn
all of which really quadrupled the skill
required to play at least compared to
something like hearthstone and finally
we arrived at Gwent originally this was
a mini game in which a trilogy and this
standalone development is a vastly
improved experience I adore this game
and it's improving with every patch so
to explain how it works
quent is nothing like other card games
to start you can only play one card per
turn which contributes points to your
total scene here on the left side of the
board the player with the highest amount
of points wins the round and in order to
win a game of Gwent you have to win two
out of three rounds which means that
usually both players will be angling for
the perfect moment to lose one round on
purpose this is done by pressing down on
the coin and
passing when it's your turn you can give
up around like this at any point during
your turn which gives you both some
control over how long rounds will last
which eventually culminates in a long or
a short round 3 some decks like eridan
Frost love long rounds they play a ton
of frost on the opponent's board which
strips away their power over time and
they try to pressure their opponent to
give up round 1 early so that eridan can
take them to a long frosty round three
other decks like bran Queen's Guard love
short rounds they will often spend an
entire round just sending their own
cards to the graveyard and then
strengthening them while they're still
in the graveyard only to resurrect them
in a very short round 3 - absolutely
overwhelm their opponent with all this
power that they've built up in previous
rounds and Gwent isn't about playing as
many cards as you can on curve like
hearthstone or even jeweler star sure
your cards do gain more value if they're
played in the correct order but what
went is really about is pitting your own
win condition against your opponent's
win condition it's about playing to
fulfil your decks strengths and playing
to disrupt theirs
eridan for example can play a card
called caretaker which is a legendary
card that will pull brands strengthened
Queens guard right out of his graveyard
and use it for our own that was his win
condition and now it's ours to retaliate
bran may well have saved all of his
frost clearing cards for a long round 3
which wasn't what eridan was expecting
with both of their traditional wind
conditions disrupted it comes down to
whichever player maneuvered and bluffed
the most effectively Gwent wins the dark
souls of card games award with flying
colors not just because it's a skill
based game
the better player will win the majority
of the time but because the devs are
just so damn good to their community
this game is very generous to its new
players and it gives you in-game
currency and packs at every turn play
all the tutorials have some free packs
like watching twitch streams you have a
chance at being gifted a pack oh and
here's some free resources because my
opponent thought that was a good game
you get packs for every few rounds one
for ranking up for every season for
levelling up for completing quests I
don't buy packs in this game because I
need them I support this game out of
appreciation for this consumer friendly
dev team and because I want more of
these gorgeous premium artworks the
challenge that Gwent faces is
maintaining this high skill cap while
also attracting new players for example
their recent 100 card expansion seems to
imply that they're gearing up for an
arena-style draft mode and an iOS or
Android version as a result a lot of
cards have become a bit simpler and one
has to hope that they don't lose too
much identity in pursuit of
accessibility
if Gwent wants to seriously compete with
hearthstone
I think that they need to offer
something that the popular game doesn't
already do though one idea I fancied for
a really long time is a tournament mode
a mode where you're thrown into a series
of games with a bunch of other people
with the promise of riches or just ego
if you come out on top there's something
incredibly addictive about being thrown
into a competitive free-for-all with a
ton of other players this year the
battle royale revolution was
kick-started with player unknowns
battlegrounds pub G has some of the
worst in-game rewards I've ever seen
admittedly yet millions of people were
still driven to compete for that chicken
dinner I remember my first win vividly I
yelled out when I secured the final spot
not many games can give you that rush
which makes it addictive regardless of
the
game rewards that said while pub G has
some of the highest highs in gaming it
does also have some of the lowest lows
imaginable
you'll lose so many games too clunky
movement lag and problems with the
physics engine it'll take you a lot of
games to get used to every gun since
there's no good way to practice and
it'll take you a lot of money to buy a
PC that can run this game properly in a
way pub G is kind of a victim of its own
popularity how driven will the devs
really be to make their game better when
millions play already
how likely will they be to take risks
with their beta design when the
slightest mistake in their code causes
millions of people to erupt in outrage I
feel like pub G is seriously failing to
make the most of its beta phase and I
think that it's partly due to all of
these negative factors that space has
been created for a far more polished
game to erupt onto the scene fortnight
battle royale actually deserves the
award more than pub G does in my opinion
fortnight runs like a dream compared to
pub G and offers a more progressive
tiered loot system that actually makes
your character feel more powerful as you
kill more people which is a really good
thing in battle royale where a strategy
can be to just play super defensively
and not kill anyone no you want to be
incentivized to kill people and in pub G
I didn't really feel that in fortnight
there are potions that increase your
maximum health guns that are
legitimately exciting to pick up because
there's a bit of RNG involved and
materials that increase your
survivability and ability to build in
the late-game a fortnight sacrifices
realism in favour of gameplay and its
cartoony aesthetic allows it to get away
with gameplay innovations that pub G
never can and never will attempt
anyway let's talk about Game of the Year
candidates 2017 was a really incredible
year for gaming for me personally but
that's kind of because when I enjoy
games I tend to focus on them to the
exclusion of all other games and I know
there are a ton more out there that I'm
not covering so I need your help in the
description there is a poll with a ton
more games and a ton more categories
than I can cover alone considering I
came up with the idea for this video a
little bit too late in the year so
please vote for your favorites down
below for me the year started with neo
it was my first taste of a triple a
Souls like game that actually got most
things right and even managed to
innovate on top of the souls formula the
devs actually took a ton of feedback
from Souls veterans and they created
something really special I loved it
then came breath of the wild it
completely sold me on the viability of
the switch as a gaming platform to the
point where I'd probably call it my
favorite console thus far I feel way
more inclined to play single-player
games on this thing which is new for me
and Zelda was the first bit of proof
that Nintendo is handling it's switch
IPS with a lot of care
I bought a Wii U so this is new to me it
was nice to play a Zelda game that
wasn't so linear easy or predictable it
actually felt like an adventure which
really took me back to playing ocarina
of time as a kid
Mario Odyssey was a great game too it
has Bar None the most polished movement
I think I've ever experienced in a game
it's absolutely genius how much movement
you have with just one jump button but I
have to say I was actually a bit
disappointed that very few levels
actually require you to use all of your
moves earlier in the difficulty awards
section I was talking about how
difficult games really put the mechanics
of a game to the test
and Odyssey is the perfect example of
that problem I think only a handful of
levels like the ones that I'm showing on
screen now required in-depth knowledge
and execution of Mario's moves and I
think this game could have been my game
of the year if there were more
challenging levels like this but still a
great game but nothing nothing had as
much wasted potential in my opinion as
foreigner did I played the hell out of
foreigner I was drawn in by the medieval
combat and I got my first real taste of
why fighting games must be so much fun
at its best Verona requires you to look
for patterns in your enemy's playstyle
and then predict and punish them
accordingly
the skill cap in this game was huge to
the point where the best players would
focus on one character and attempt to
play every match up perfectly the
problem was most of the cast of
characters were blatantly underpowered
and good characters like warden or
warlord were good because they had a
couple of risk free almost unpunished
ball attacks months went by and nothing
changed the community clamored for
tweaks and wrote a ton of really good
suggestions but to this day I'm pretty
sure the game still has a lot of the
same problems they did at launch it
rewards players who play super defensive
and it encourages you to buy the DLC
characters who actually have developed
movesets
they created something really unique and
special with fauna but I'll be much more
cautious about falling in love with fur
on a--to and so my personal game of the
year the game that's given me the most
fun the most wholesome feeling of
community apart from souls and the most
hope for the future is Gwent The Witcher
card game as of the release of this
video quent will have just received a
100 card expansion and
a ton of visual upgrades to animations
and the UI if you're looking for a time
to get into this game now is the time
because there's also a Christmas deal on
packs if you did want to get a head
start on your collection and as I've
mentioned this is a good dev team that
worth supporting in early 2018 we'll
also be receiving the single player
throne breaker campaign which appears to
have this mixture of story deck building
exploration and of course playing the
actual game this game has got better
with every patch and I think it's
something worth keeping an eye on if
this is what you're into in the
description I've listed a bunch of Handy
Gwent guides Gwent streamers and decks
to help you try and get started it's not
as easy as some of the card games on the
market but it is well worth your time so
please vote in the poll down below and
Merry Christmas everybody